did either of them speak to you in the
run-up to this dive did they talk of any
concerns that they might have had
absolutely there was a common point of
discussion within the community about
the design risks of the submersible that
they were going on and they asked my
opinion and I said that I would not get
in that submersible and I think pH was
part of their organization to try and do
his best to try and mitigate some of the
safety concerns because he was the most
experienced person in Diamond the
Titanic maybe in history and Hamish I
think just really really desired to go
see the Titanic and there had been many
successful times on Titanic with Ocean
Gate and maybe he thought that it was
worthy of the risk and that it was safe
enough but we all in the community had
concerns and unfortunately those proved
out to be true